Africa is where I sport up it's a place
that completely fills me with excitement
enjoy the heat the thorns the smells to
me it's all hugely evocative African
wildlife is so diverse 6:18 is such a
movement such a lot of character all
these things to me make sculpture I'm
markers I mean it's got them I'm here
specifically looking for one very big
elephant or one ton next month next year
that may never be another animal this
scale so I think in a way it's almost a
sort of capturing a moment in time I
want to find one of these magnificent
animals and
[Music]
if every sculptor works in his own way
but for me to get out into the field and
really look for common priest faced with
the fun subject matter is I far the best
approach because you have to really work
with
my local guide for this trip is a
wonderful man called James he was born
reporter very near to here he could read
the ground he can read the store he can
read the prints through the dust he knew
where and how to look his territories
big is that for me
150 kilometers long you know he's
dominant in the areas here maybe
somewhere chasing around Venus these are
the things that I as a guest naira we
really never be able to access I take my
wire and my plasticine and make field
studies of the animals I'm after these
fields that is already a
three-dimensional form of sketching
there are my sketches round use for the
war finished work and studio that can be
almost valuable because it captures the
spirit of split second their movement is
sexual love the complete that big
sculpture that bigs really good
sculpture
[Music]
one time is the big dollar mail give
this district
apparently he disappears for days at a
time
some hoping hoping hoping that he comes
back to water or something he's going to
me it's everything that you're learning
on the journey there the environment
that you're walking through the
temperatures that use the coal the dust
the plains of mountains the rocks
all these things are telling you the
story about that hair
[Music]
at one time one done oh what a boy Wow I
am just enjoying this
when you find your subject you are on
edge you're you're so tuned up soon that
little sighting of an extraordinary
magnificent beast that you've been
hunting for a weeks to find is really
the veteran the left task the very long
one girl can weigh up to 80 kilos yeah
take your calculator left task is worth
eight hundred thousand US dollars it's
more than gold and that's why these guys
are disappearing when I'm very alarming
yet about fifty years ago
guys like one time there were thousands
but now as we talk in this ecosystem
which is 2 million acres we only have
two really sad
[Music]
but I got now Jews to instantly look it
in my eyes my mind of the camera yeah
and I couldn't afford it room right
because then when I get back home into
my studio I should go just record
everything right I got it
since it's a little funny and sculpt a
huge elephant it does add a little bit
of adrenaline rush budget but it has a
little of reality
[Music]
it's an animal that is full probably as
full of emotions we are as human beings
and yes it's a beast that is soon is
those emotions and his movements that I
want to Tran betrayin province as a
marker of fueling remaining really big
elephant that exists on this planet
I pay much
do not try smooth might be starting to
almost photographic detail That's not me
at all the message I'm trying to give is
one of movement of life and it's rarely
being in the field would you see this
movement life in its extreme as it is
different you lose these little Bliss's
terms that you would never see unless
you are matches they're very taking it
in it's all actually this one smidge
away from the environment being part of
a sculpture
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you